bonsoir impossible d'en bas merci d'être
avec nous vous avez déclaré hier vivre
un simulacre de procès un règlement de
compte politique visant à écarter
guillaume soro pourquoi de tels mots ben
parce que c'est ce que c'est
malheureusement c'est un simulacre de
procès et donc nous avons décidé de ne
pas y colle pas pourquoi la tenue de
cette audience c'est même une insulte
aux deux décisions qui ont été rendus
par la cour africaine des droits de
l'homme
elle a pris une décision très claire
l'année dernière 2020 le 22 avril 2020
exactement pour dire qu'il fallait gérer
la procédure ce qui concerne monsieur
guillaume kigbafori soro et libéré tous
ses proches
ensuite le 15 dès septembre 2020 elle a
repris mme de nos décisions dans ce qui
s'est vu écarté par la commission
électorale indépendante et ne pas être
déclaré comme candidat la cour africaine
s'était prononcée le nouveau elle avait
dit qu'il fallait qu'il soit candidat et
que ses droits politiques soient
respectés donc rien que pour le respect
de cette décision
l'audience d'aujourd'hui n'auraient
jamais dû se tenir et pour nous c'est
une mascarade alors ce que quand on
respecte droit quand on a un minimum de
respect de la primauté du droit parce
que les décisions de la cour africaine
sont revêtus du droit de la primauté du
droit international s'est reconnu dans
toutes les constitutions des pays y
compris de la côte d'ivoire la côte
d'ivoire dont on aurait dû en respectant
cette décision considéré que cette
décision avait une force supérieure à
celle des décisions internes et les
magistrats auraient dû donc gelé toute
la procédure et attendre que les juges
africains donc de cette cour africaine
des droits de l'homme et des peuples se
prononce sur la procédure avant d'aller
plus loin dans le dossier
alors on le rappelle à m si vous faites
partie justement des accusés comment
justement vous expliquez que là qu'on ne
l'ait pas fait en fait justement si
j'avais été inculpé dès le départ il est
évident que mon nom aurait été dans ceux
de toutes les personnes qui ont été
entendues dans la requête a été déposée
devant la cour africaine des droits de
l'homme
mais je n'étais pas
dans le dossier moi même et certains de
mes compagnons qui se retrouvent aussi
être en exil comme le président du gps
monsieur guillaume kigbafori soro
il s'agit donc de touré moussa ici à
carfos à la le député à monsieur bell
souk tous n'avons pas été cité dans la
procédure n'avons pas été cité dans le
réquisitoire introductif d'instance
donc nous n'avons pas été que nous
n'avons pas été entendus
tout le long de la procédure et
subitement à la fin on apprend donc que
nous serons aussi donc renvoyé comme
tous les autres devant le juge criminel
ça même pas devant le tribunal
correctionnel
devant le juge criminel pour être jugé
et cela au mépris encore une fois de
plus du code de procédure pénal ivoirien
à l'article 208 209 qui dit qu'une
personne doit être inculpé formellement
par rapport aux réquisitoires donc
introductif du procureur et ensuite on
après devant les juridictions donc
devant le tribunal correctionnel où le
tribunal criminel
ce qui n'est pas mon cas dont vous
imaginez ya tellement de je dirais de
faussetés dans ce dossier il ya
tellement de grossièretés on se pose la
question de savoir comment des
magistrats qui ont fait un minimum de
d'études de droit qui sont des
techniciens de droit on tue se prêtait
donc à ce jeu vous êtes donc à distance
comment comptez vous organiser votre
défense et celle de guillaume
soro à distance non nous avons que les
ti d'avocats et ce collectif donc que je
coordonne le collectif d'avocats des
avocats qui sont parole de côte d'ivoire
et au barreau de paris
je crois comme ce collectif et nous
avions des avocats qui étaient présents
à cette audience parce que bon il ya
monsieur guillaume kigbafori soro il ya
moi même et les autres mais également
ceux qui sont exigeants tout à leur vote
s'il me vous avez parlé du salet
lobognon monsieur souleymane camara t
les freins du président soro donc si mon
sort on est tous ceux là ont besoin
aussi d'être assisté par les avocats
dont nous avons des avocats qui
assistent à l'audience mais ce qu'il est
important de dire je crois que nous
l'avons répété tout le long de la
procédure
depuis l'année dernière nous avons dit
qu'il s'agissait d'une mascarade que
c'était vraiment un acharnement
judiciaire contre une personne et je
crois que là aujourd'hui tout le monde
s'en rendent même celui qui ne connaît
pas le droit c'est à dire n'importe quel
quidam peut voir aujourd'hui que c'est
c'est du n'importe quoi je vous assure
que l'audience d'aujourd'hui
- la limite je dirais que j'ai de la
peine pour ces magistrats comme on peut
se prêter à une telle parodie et je
crois même que le mont parodie est trop
faible pour exprimer exactement ce qui
s'est passé nous avons donc le président
le cheikh hassan matar qui a dit
clairement qu'il n'allait jamais
appliqué la décision de la cour
africaine il a dit et nous avons une
vidéo qui le recul indique qu'ils ont
très clairement
deuxièmement il a dit que guillaume
kigbafori soro eau prendrait la
perpétuité
il a dit au cours d'une interview qui
est donc de notoriété publique
un docu réalité du service à ouattara
c'est luc et le procureur donc monsieur
adou richard n'est personne en réalité
cette marionnette c'est lui qui est le
magistrat instructeur
donc c'est lui qui instruit le dossier
le doyen des juges d'instruction
monsieur victor ousmane coulibaly en
réalité n'est qu'un chemin entre ses
mains et enfin c'est lui qui juge
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que la
décision est déjà arrêtée elle a été
déjà rédigé par le sahara central
ouattara et elle ne sera donc
énoncée par les magistrats c'est tout
donc voilà en gros la samantha ma
fenêtre ou salut qui poursuit on me le
suis il juge donc vous augmentez la de
services indépendants soit de la justice
au coeur de ce crime est clairement ce
qu'il avance c'est clairement ça au
coeur de ce dossier d'accusation
un enregistrement audio ce vide de
guillaume soro on l'entend parler d'un
projet d'insurrection et qu'est ce que
vous pouvez nous dire sur cet
enregistrement
mais sur l'enregistrement je pourrais à
la limite vous poser la question en tant
que journaliste si vous pensez un radier
telle personne je ne les aime pas je
vais la tuer
est-ce que vous avez commis un crime non
non je vous pose la question ça veut
donc dire quoi ça veut donc dire en se
contentant dans une audio et le passage
à l'acte ça fait deux donc ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que le fait de le dire
ne suffit pas c'est pour ça que le droit
pénal il faut la constitution de trois
éléments qui sont très importants est
l'élément légal est l'élément
intentionnel est en fait un élément
matériel qui matérialise le passage à
l'acte mais il ya un tel élément
matériel
nous n'avons aucun élément matériel
outils voilà il ya un complot contre aux
gens mais aussi les bacs est ce que vous
craignez le plus vous craignez une
extradition pour vous cette affaire
malaise mais je viens de vous le
démontrer a même pas d'extradition
possible parce que justement j'allais
signer par là c'est que la décision des
magistrats ivoiriens
cette décision ne sera appliquée qu'en
côte d'ivoire cei décision ivoiro
ivoirienne qui tournera en côte d'ivoire
elle ne sera jamais appliqué dans aucun
pays qui se respecte on l y manque de
respect pour le droit et je voudrais je
finirai peut-être par là quand vous
voyez le décisions parfois des
magistrats vous savez qu'ils peuvent
prendre une décision en tordant le cou
au droit et vous vous dites bon c'est
vrai que cette décision elle tord le cou
au droit mais c'est tellement bien
rédigé tellement bien argumenté qu'à la
limite vous êtes je dirais admiratif de
cette décision mais là il s'agit d'une
grossière et tellement grave et sa main
la côte d'ivoire définitivement au rang
d'état voyou sous alassane ouattara
cette décision ne sera plus quelque part
les magistrats ivoiriens
elle ne sera appliquée pas aucun aucune
autre juridiction d'aucun pays au monde
mais un jour d'hiver
mais beaucoup à fossiles man-made avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france